the attack came in the early hours of
the morning many people were in bed it
was quick it was devastating
a nine story building partially
destroyed the rockets fired from russian
aircraft according to local authorities
pictures from the scene in odessa were
quickly uploaded to social media
so many people have taken shelter from
possible attacks in the basement of
buildings but to carefully move the
debris trying to find one more person to
save
in the ukrainian parliament they held a
moment of silence for those killed in
the attack which also hit a local
recreation center
in order for ukrainian mornings not to
start so tragically as it started today
with missile strikes at odessa in odessa
region today's morning started with a
lot of victims we want mornings of
ukrainians to become as peaceful as the
mornings of each european capital in the
21st century
the attack came just hours after russian
president vladimir putin insisted his
forces do not target civilian areas
our army does not attack any civilian
infrastructure we have every capability
of knowing what is situated and where
ukrainian generals say the number of
russian missile attacks has more than
doubled in the past two weeks
and they believe they are using more
soviet-era missiles which are much less
accurate and that means more civilian
areas may be hit
whether they are targeted or not alan
fisher al-jazeera kiev